el descarrilamiento de un tren con
sustancias químicas tóxicas en Ohio
tiene enfrentados en Estados Unidos
ambientalistas residentes del lugar y a
políticos de ambos partidos por la mala
gestión en el manejo de los residuos
tras el accidente la activista erin
brokovic visitó el lugar del derrame
he estado en muchas situaciones
medioambientales y nunca en mi vida he
visto nada tan mal gestionado jamás
das el visto bueno pero no tienes datos
que demuestren que está todo claro y
luego cuando la gente vuelve y te dice
estoy oliendo cosas estamos enfermos
vamos a urgencias No puedo respirar
hacen caso omiso porque todo es seguro
es obvio que nada es seguro todavía
y es que las pruebas de la contaminación
podrían estar en la población misma que
ve como comienzan a aparecer
enfermedades en la zona estoy criando a
tres nietas han tenido sarpullidos han
enfermas la hija de Giovanni otro
residente local ha estado enferma
después de ir al colegio intentan
obligarnos a volver a nuestras casas a
ir al colegio y decir que no pasa nada
pero los niños están enfermos y eso no
lo voy a
tolerards solo queremos respuestas solo
respuestas todos los ciudadanos de
Palestina este necesitamos respuestas Y
no la estamos obteniendo
ellos esperan respuestas del operador
ferroviario norford y la agencia de
protección del medio ambiente de Estados
Unidos en medio de las críticas por la
gestión del vertido políticos
republicanos Atacan al presidente Joe
biden por no haber viajado al lugar del
desastre y porque la respuesta Federal
según ellos demuestra que los demócratas
no están centrados en la política
nacional